The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Here we
demonstrate the effects
of sampling and
aliasing by using
this non-recursive
digital filter.
Where as a digital
filter, it's simply
set up as an identity system.
But we take
advantage of the fact
that it has a
sampler for the input
and a de-sampler for the output.
To demonstrate the sampling
and aliasing effect,
we'll use a sinusoidal input.
And so on the oscilloscope,
what we have are two traces.
The top trace is
the input sinusoid.
And the bottom trace
is the output sinusoid.
And we know that we expect
that as the input sinusoidal
frequency is increased, the
output sinusoidal frequency
will likewise increase until we
get into the vicinity of half
the sampling frequency.
In the vicinity of half the
sampling frequency, because
of the fact that the low pass
filter is not an ideal low pass
filter, we have
a beating effect.
And we see the beating
effect evident here.
Now if we were to increase
the input frequency
past the half the
sampling frequency,
even though the input
frequency would increase,
the output frequency would
decrease due to aliasing.
And let's illustrate that
by first moving back down
toward DC.
And then using an
automatic sweep,
to sweep us from DC through
half the sampling frequency up
to the sampling frequency.
And so here we get
in the vicinity
of half the sampling frequency.
We see the beating effect.
Past that, the output
frequency decreases,
even though the input
frequency is increasing.
And now, let's illustrate
that once more.
But in this case, let's
listen to the output
as well as watching the output.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
We hear it increase.
And then we hear the
output frequency decrease.
[FREQUENCY STOPS]
What we see here is the impulse
response of the overall system.
And we observe, for one thing,
that it's a symmetrical impulse
response.
In other words, corresponds
to a linear phase filter.
We can also look at
the impulse response
before the de-sampling
low pass filter.
Lets take out the de-sampling
low pass filter slowly.
And what we observe is
basically the output
of the digital to
analog converter.
Which of course, is a staircase
or boxcar function, not
an impulse train.
In the real world, the
output of a D to A converter
generally is a boxcar
type of function.
We can put the de-sampling
filter back in now.
And notice that the effect
of the de-sampling filter
is basically to smooth out
the rough edges in the boxcar
output from D to A converter.
Now what we'd like to illustrate
is the frequency response
of the equivalent
continuous time filter.
And we can do that by
sweeping the filter
with a sinusoidal input.
So what we'll see in
this demonstration is
on the upper trace, the input
sinusoid, on the lower trace,
the output sinusoid.
Using a 20 kilohertz sampling
rate and a sweep from 0
to 10 kilohertz, in
other words, a sweep
from 0 to effectively pi in
terms of the digital filter.
So what we'll
observe as the input
frequency increases is
that the output sinusoid
will have essentially constant
amplitude up to the cutoff
frequency of the filter,
and then approximately zero
amplitude past.
So let's now sweep the
filter frequency response.
And there is the filter
cutoff frequency.
Now we can also observe the
filter frequency responds
in several other ways.
One way in which
we can observe it
is by looking also
at the amplitude
of the output sinusoid as
a function of frequency
rather than as a
function of time.
And so we'll observe that
on the left hand scope.
While on the right
hand scope, we'll
have the same trace that we
just saw, namely two traces.
The upper trace is
the input sinusoid.
The lower trace is
the output sinusoid.
And in addition to observing
the frequency response,
let's also listen to
the output sinusoid
and observe the
attenuation in the output
as we go from the filter
passband to the filter
stopband.
Again, a 20 kilohertz
sampling rate.
And a sweep range from
0 to 10 kilohertz.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
Now of course, we're
in the filter stopband.
Now if we increase the sweep
range from 10 kilohertz to 20
kilohertz so that the sweep
range is equal to the sampling
frequency, in essence
that corresponds
to sweeping out the digital
filter from 0 to 2 pi.
And in that case,
we'll begin to see
some of the periodicity in
the digital filter frequency
response.
So let's do that now with a
20 kilohertz sampling rate
and a sweep range of
0 to 20 kilohertz.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
And now we come near 2 pi we
get back into the passband.
And finally back to a 0
to 10 kilohertz sweep, so
that we're again sweeping
only from 0 to pi with regard
to the digital filter.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
OK, now what we would
like to demonstrate
is the effect of changing
the sampling frequency.
And we know that the effective
filter cutoff frequency is
tied to the sampling frequency.
And for this particular
filter, corresponds to a tenth
of the sampling frequency.
Consequently, if we double
the sampling frequency,
we should double the effective
filter passband width
or double the filter
cutoff frequency.
And so let's do that now.
Again, a 0 to 10 kilohertz
sweep range, but a 40 kilohertz
sampling frequency.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
And we should observe that the
filter cutoff frequency has now
doubled to 4 kilohertz.
Now let's begin to decrease
the filter sampling frequency.
So from 40, let's change
the sampling frequency
to 20 kilohertz.
We should see the cutoff
frequency cut in half.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
Now we can go even further.
We can cut the sampling
frequency down to 10 kilohertz.
And remember that the sweep
range is zero to 10 kilohertz.
So now we'll be
sweeping from 0 to 2 pi.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
So as we get close to 2 pi
we'll see the passband again.
And now let's cut down the
sampling frequency even further
to 5 kilohertz.
[SHORT HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
Here we are at 2 pi.
[HIGH PITCH FREQUENCY]
And then at 4 pi.
All right, so that
illustrates the effect
of changing the
sampling frequency.
Now let's conclude
this demonstration
of the effect of the sampling
frequency on the filter cutoff
frequency by carrying out some
filtering on some live audio.
What we'll watch, in this case,
is the output audio waveform
as a function of time on
the single trace scope.
And also, we'll
listen to the output.
We'll begin it with a 40
kilohertz sampling rate,
then reduce that to 20
kilohertz, 10 kilohertz,
and then 5 kilohertz.
And in each of those cases,
the effective filter cutoff
frequency then is cut
in half from 4 kilohertz
to 2 kilohertz to 1 kilohertz
and then to 500 cycles.
So let's begin with a 40
kilohertz sampling frequency,
or an effective filter cutoff
frequency of 4 kilohertz.
[MUSIC - SCOTT JOPLIN, "MAPLE
LEAF RAG"]
Now let's reduce
that to 20 kilohertz
sampling frequency or
a 2 kilohertz filter.
Then a 10 kilohertz
sampling frequency.
And finally, a 5 kilohertz
sampling frequency
corresponding to a 500 cycle
equivalent analog filter.
All right, now let's
finally conclude
by returning to a little
higher quality ragtime
by changing the sampling
frequency back to 40 kilohertz.